I do want to hear the whole story what I
was trying to do is give you the benefit
of the doubt which was you you found
this thing really helpful now I know for
your kids for your family and you're
like I want to share this with the world
which I think is a beautiful thing I
think that's great
what I want to know is when it got out
of line my assumption was that you want
to play a character that was larger than
life because that could touch more
people and by touching more people you
could probably help them I think that's
best case scenario for you now using the
performance enhancing drugs allowed you
to have this like you see this in
cartoons bro this is this is not like a
real thing that you see regularly right
and because of it when you're scrolling
on Instagram and you see a guy walking
around like that you're like what the
[ __ ] is going on right I think this
makes sense sure you're walking around
the liver like all these things like the
way that you create the virality around
you is very impressive it's brilliant
it's it's genuinely impressive and your
comfort doing podcasts on that stuff
having never been in entertainment
before incredibly impressive so there
are components to this where as someone
who's in entertainment I go wow this guy
knows what the [ __ ] he's doing
what I'm curious about is when did it
get out of your control if you will and
why lie and why lie yeah yeah you know
almost immediately it got out of control
because almost immediately you know this
question was asked you know if I'm
taking anything and and so why lie I
shared this before I'll share with you
guys I mean the mind is such an
incredible weapon and I'd convinced
myself of a couple of things I'll just
tell you three of them you know the
first is I'm like what the [ __ ] does
this have to do with my message this is
what I'm thinking right I'm thinking
this has nothing to do with how people
are hurting and hating and The Simple
Solution to live a better life I'm
thinking what the [ __ ] does this have to
do with my message yeah I'm not going to
talk I would say you convinced me what
day I should talk about these
accusations versus the day we should
talk about the hurting and hating and
the path to better [ __ ] life you tell
me what day we should do that today so I
convinced myself of that right right
um the second thing is like I'm thinking
what the [ __ ] sport am I playing right
who the [ __ ] am I cheating again I'm not
saying any of this is right I understand
we're not giving any pushback I I
genuinely just want to know what was
going through your mind and these things
seem reasonable this is what goes to my
mind and I'm thinking about you know how
many 15 year olds have dm'd me I wish
you were my dad whoa you know I hate the
[ __ ] life that I live in yeah I hate
myself you know and I wish you were my
dad and I'm thinking oh God damn you
know
um I convinced myself that this is not
the message that this 15 year old needs
to hear so I just [ __ ] kept digging
you guys know do you remember the first
I think people empathize with you lie
about something and then it just gets
whatever but like do you remember when
you first lied and what went through
your mind and like you remember that
moment
you know what um not exactly I do
remember that Logan Paul gave me the
opportunity yeah to come unimpulsive and
and I remember them asking me then you
know and I remember oh [ __ ] okay you
know this is what I'm gonna say and I
started saying it and then once I said
that you know like I'm [ __ ] done it's
over yeah yeah you gotta dig in yeah you
know and and yeah talk about doubling
down and tripling down I mean you know I
keep telling people this is the
stupidest [ __ ] thing I ever did yeah
yeah you know if you plan to do that
before you went on the show like was the
conversation like oh if they asked say
this or was that something that came up
well people had already asked the DMS
people had already you know been
commenting about it were you responding
to DMS or just yeah okay I was and so I
already had started lying about it and
so once again like this all went through
my head the first time somebody asked
I'm like okay I convinced myself of X Y
and Z so I'm not going to come out and
share that information yeah why the [ __ ]
does it matter will this information
ever come out you know and uh yeah once
you start [ __ ] lying you're you're
done yeah you're [ __ ] done
um I will say that there's so many
[ __ ] silver lightings in life though
yep and and I don't know if you guys
know this but like as soon as this
happened I called Derek I called him
first of all he didn't answer yeah and
then I sent him a text and I said hey
man I just want to say I just want to
thank you and so then he answers I'm
like hey man um oh actually the first
thing I said to him he answers he goes
hello and I said hey
um how [ __ ] long did it take for you
to make this documentary yeah yeah yeah
and he goes weeks I said weeks you spent
weeks making this documentary I think
it's brilliant yeah and I just want to
say thank you I don't know what good
will come of it but good will [ __ ]
come of it um I'm on the [ __ ] show
right now yeah you know I'm on I have
this opportunity to be completely
[ __ ] honest with my boys I've been
lying to my my boys my own boys wow you
know about this now is it in some ways
liberating completely carrying around a
lie maybe I'm sure your wife knows about
it and forcing her to lie I don't know
if the kids know about it but basically
you're carrying around this lie that
people get crushed under that pressure
especially when your identity is rooted
in your physique the other thing I think
two things happen uh for sure it felt
like a weight had been lifted yeah for
about five seconds and then immediately
[Laughter]
and immediately it's like you know what
like you you know what I what I'm
dealing with now yeah you know of course
I'm gonna own it and of course you know
like now I have a deeper sense of
obligation and responsibility to remain
to my true north to get this message out
because of the people that were counting
on me irrespective of it if it happens
with the liver King brand or not you
know I've always said I'm the CEO of the
ancestral lifestyle here's the thing I
need a hundred [ __ ] CEOs of the
ancestral lifestyle you know if this
thing's gonna work yeah you know if this
goes mainstream and we get people to
execute at a deep level it's like this
this is way bigger than me and so for a
second I'm like oh cool the weight has
been lifted
um now now do you think that there is
pushback because okay let me put phrase
all this I don't think you're getting
nearly as much pushback if you just
happen to be an accountant
that looked like this and preach the
ancestral Lifestyle the fact that you
had businesses that were profiting off
of it I think makes people give pushback
and I think the second you mentioned how
much money the businesses were making
once you put money out there Envy
follows and they want to tear that ass
down yeah so so I what is your thought
on that do you think if you weren't
profiting off of the way you look and
simply just pushing it that you would
get next to this much screw yeah the
first thing I'll say is litter King just
launched a year ago a year and a few
months yeah I've been in business since
supplement businesses since 2014. right
I mean with Liberty the public figures
brand [ __ ] knew right and what I can
tell you is uh my businesses have always
grown a certain amount that amount
hasn't increased nor has it decreased
um so what another thing I'll say is
like
um you know again the two North is the
nine ancestral tenants yeah no anyone
can sit here and say oh your businesses
are profiting you know all I really
[ __ ] give listen you don't gotta you
know uh I'm I'm really speaking more
towards perception because right now we
operate in perception not reality right
the internet is that that is the reality
exactly so perception becomes reality so
when they say my businesses are when
they see a headline this like liver
King's business makes 100 million
dollars last year they're assuming you
pushing liver King not your other
supplements that have nothing to do with
you that people don't even know the
brands that are exactly Associated
they're just saying 100 million dollars
liver King products then they find out
you're on steroids they're like this
[ __ ] was lying about his body so
we could sell these liver King bars and
make hundreds of millions of dollars
[ __ ] that guy adding to their hatred
think about how many take the liver king
bar by the way did you bring anything
that's [ __ ] good lifetime supply for
everybody
bring them out I gave you a whole spread
you didn't give me names
so so I guess what I'm trying to uh get
to is like more the perception right
because we're operating perception you
can empathize with somebody that sees
that oh 100
I deserve it they should be resentful
about it you know again like I apologize
because I lied because I deceived people
because I misled people again I [ __ ]
own it I deserve it all right you know
and what I would say to anybody who
wants to retaliate or go somewhere else
go somewhere else right what I would ask
you got to be loyal to the facts that
people are hurting and hitting at record
rates
you want to go somewhere else go
somewhere else I don't give a [ __ ]
you're like yeah get these things from
huberman get these things from the many
other people that are preaching very
similar philosophies that will help you
with your life right so you're saying it
doesn't need to be liver King who's
pointing these things out it could be
Derek from more places but guess what
every one of them saying the same thing
they're all saying liver is King and
they're saying make sure you you get an
ice bath make sure you look at the Sun
make sure you do all these things
clearly these things work you call them
in the ancestral tenants hugerman's
gonna call them something else more
place more days it's going to call them
Rogan's gonna call them something else
but what you're saying right now it's
more important to you that people do
these things so they could feel better
than they just follow you as their lord
and savior this is my why in the world
got you now my question is this because
I saw the apology and I thought it was
great that you apologize now can you
also
empathize with the people that felt that
you were using the suicide stuff as a
shield to protect you sure you know what
else is this um
my 10 to 15 year old self was the
hardest [ __ ] time in my life I'm
grateful for it this was my first rite
of passage in life
um every day I got this [ __ ] kicked out
of me like I said I'm grateful for it
yeah um but here's what I remember in
Middle School by bus driver killed
himself oh no and um and every day prior
to that I remember looking in the mirror
just wishing I wasn't this [ __ ] guy
zero self-worth totally humiliated and
embarrassed of the human that I had
become
um when he killed himself now I [ __ ]
knew it was possible you know and I knew
the world would be better without me
um I could talk more about those years
if you want me to but a couple years
later my best friend's brother killed
himself I've had talks in my family
about people wanting to kill themselves
just last week we had a 14 year old girl
close to the family kill herself
um and you know what nobody wants to
talk about this yeah why the [ __ ] are
people not talking about this 4 000
people a day do it eighty thousand
people today try to [ __ ] do it
somewhere along the Continuum people are
suffering and struggling at record
[ __ ] rates so this this is what I
would say back number one this is why
I'm [ __ ] here the only reason why I'm
here
um and then secondly I think when
somebody has the opportunity to talk
about it you better [ __ ] talk about
it it's dangerous if you don't it's
irresponsible if you don't so you want
to laugh and say oh he's just saying
this to do that thing you know and I
know you're not laughing but other
people are saying oh he's shielding I
was very like for me I'm very sensitive
with that kind of stuff because I have
close family members who have been
suicidal we all have 100 right so like
me not knowing those things about you my
knee-jerk reaction was like whoa whoa
whoa are you using this thing as a
shield I've seen certain people use the
suicide thing as a shield for like
protection from the ugly beliefs they
have like it's it's a it's a it's a
topic that's used often to be like well
I know I said this [ __ ] up [ __ ] but by
the way did you know this is happening
to Men We need to look out for men we
need to be careful and we need to we
need to we nurture them and everybody's
forgetting men when you tell me that
you've had these close people in your
life kill themselves immediately I
empathize oh [ __ ] man he really does
care about this stuff he went through a
tough time in his life kids couldn't
even [ __ ] breathe you're trying to
find ways to make life easier for people
now you're a person now you're Brian
Johnson now you're not liver King the
problem with creating the mascot of the
cartoon is they don't have feelings they
don't have family they don't have
emotions to the consumer right [ __ ]
the guy on um Captain Crunch oh know
what he went through I don't know how
many cousins he got do you know what I'm
saying I don't know that's just the
Captain Crunch guy who sells me crunch
berries and that is kind of similar the
benefit of being Captain Crunch is you
can be everywhere yeah but the problem
is nobody gives a [ __ ] about your
feelings so for me that makes me feel
better when my knee-jerk reaction was
like oh I think that's a shield I think
a shield that I'm really sensitive about
if you can talk also to that because I
think the perception some people might
still have is yeah but you the
perception not the reality is yeah but
you didn't really start talking about
this until you got exposed so if it
mattered to you so much why weren't you
leading with that before and I could be
wrong I might not have watched another
video you're wrong I saw I saw you talk
about it I saw you talk about before
when I was doing something you've been
talking about this the whole conception
but the people who aren't consuming all
your content are once again just going
to see it so that's why I think it's to
be to be honest why I want you to come
on here it I I don't we don't do gotcha
interviews that's not what about I just
want to know if it's like going through
like what was going on in your life and
as these things happen and as you saw
this you know kind of runaway train
happened like you said you wanted to go
in the email from like the followers you
had to a million and then you became one
of the most viewed people on the
internet in a very short amount of time
you get all these DMS that are
reaffirming the good that you're doing
it's very easy probably to block out the
LIE when you have 15 year olds going
thank you so much for helping me you go
okay
we could do that you know what I'm
saying no I'm not saying you're Castro
you know but it's like but it's like I'm
sure there's a bunch of people that were
in Cuba going oh this [ __ ] is great
thank you we finally got some food a
bunch of other people going what the
[ __ ] is going on what happened to all my
riches you know the the road to I don't
this seems so exaggerated but like what
do they say the the uh the the road to
to Hell's paper the road towels paved a
good intentions you know I mean I don't
think that you're going to hell for this
but you do seem to have good intentions
and I do believe the intentions
um
you know it is a it's a it's a very
tricky thing it's a very tricky place
you're in yeah